(audience cheers)
Welcome back.
Before we say goodbye,
we'd like to play a quick round of-
"Drewth or Dare".
(audience cheers)
All right.
All right, we have Leah Nimmons.
Hi Leah.
Hello. How are you?
We are great. How are you?
Good. I'm happy to be here.
Very excited.
I like your cheetah skirt.
Thank you. It came on quick.
(Ross mimics cheetah)
Exchanged it for the sweatpants, just for you.
All right, what's it gonna be, a Drewth or a dare?
A Drewth please.
Okay. Hit us.
Okay.
I want to ask, if you could be invisible,
what's the first thing that you would do?
Oh, okay.
Well, all I was gonna do was go
on a date with Kim Kardashian
and Pete Davidson to get what's really going on,
(audience laughing)
I really wanna-
(audience applauding)
Yours is so much better.
Is that a good one?
Oh gosh, now I feel, okay, oh gosh.
Okay, I'm invisible.
Yeah, what are you doing?
What do you wanna do?
All I keep thinking about is food.
(audience laughing)
That's not a bad one.
I would like sneak into like a dim sum kitchen
and just like, just steal all the dim sum.
That's weird.
No, that's good.
Good soup?
You bring me home
(audience clapping)
the dim sum
and I'll give you the scoop on Kim K
and Pete.
I'll bring some dumplings
and you can tell me all about Kim K
and Pete.
Girl.
I will tell you everything.
Okay good perfect.
All right, well, thank you everybody so much
for joining us today
and choosing to spend your time with us,
because we make this show for you.
So,
take it with you.
Take it with you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat pop music)